normal TV is so much cool stuff going on
right now and yet this was your first
time kind of in the realm of mutants and
touching upon the x-men so funny now old
lawsuits come here
so with that you know booth talking to
them it's been exciting here that it
sells the thanks is here to see the
direction they wanted to go with it I
look I think everyone in this room and
everything that's on stage you know
wanted to see Marvel's very mutants
actually eventually get to March and so
that was important to us that happened
but it had to be the right project and
it had to be in the right place and I
don't think enough can be said about
accident together John Landgraf who
really sort of like fought through
incredible like duct-tape version of red
tape in order to make this happen in
that having Lauren on board you know and
made it like okay now it's kind of
really happen I
and then Noah and John just hadn't taken
it was so unique and wonderful and
vanilla burst told us a story you
couldn't deny and I think that's one of
the things the television these days and
the time I and then each person in the
cast it you know I mean I always joked
it like no again he is creative jolly in
his television show that is spring
instead and anything all of your
increase and
yeah it's a miracle model model and
again I can't say not about Noah's
Willie didn't consistent foreign-looking
that evolved the x-men franchise since
the very beginning you know was it you
know beautiful out people in wonder that
we drink explicit TV was a great you've
got to do in such a different vibe that
you know it wasn't going to be like okay
oh we don't want version of it on TV
even is because this is going to have a
logistic character not so much the only
way that you would really miss to make
it really distinctive we were very
fortunate and not being wanted no one
survived it and you know and and his
idea was further elephant cover expenses
which was all the way because it has to
insist on some plane it can't ever cross
paths with the movies or what I want
right they Jonathan for you I shouldn't
ask about a bit more about the
musicality of the show which has been a
big thing right from the pilot in your
earliest discussions with no is that
something you guys you want it's really
kind of weave in and out of the show
yeah absolutely one of the earliest
discussions was about the Bollywood
dance number
when I consider that for about 30
minutes it could respond we started to
talk about how to do nevus yeah the show
is really obviously heavily influenced
budget both the score Jeff Rizzo and the
songs that no fines and ranges it's it's
my lawyer and part of the tapestry for
sure
now Tim let me ask you you know your
character in the finale sort of was a
freed of this burden as it were that
first out sort of a lifelong burden
having played you know I know you know
sort of selling things you yet but are
you most excited and trade yourself to
see what is you know sort of David to
point out what is David without the
shadow king yes the shoulder stones are
guys I mean yeah what fills them won't
till that point and yeah there's a lot
of questions I still have to know is it
true that so I have a particular had
good interested you know you didn't
really know you didn't know for the
beginning you know what David Ark was at
the end if I kept that close to us not
too much I became convinced it will
brief was in possession of a lot more
knowledge than I was thinking of
building that's true
I think it's true but either part of the
politics is the confusion enjoying the
confusion and I think that's part of
watching the show as well you can enjoy
not knowing what is happening and trees
trying to communicate the experience
related rather than saying this man is
trying to tell you actually trying to
feel what that might be like wonderful
responsibility and then you know Rachel
for shade I mean it seems like an
understatement to say that she had her
guard up when we met her at the
beginning the show but then you know she
you know really was sort of leading the
charge that helps David for him in the
finale was sort of the pinnacle in doing
that do you think that that sort of a
little spark and hers or is you know
maybe being more proactive but also sort
of being more open to the world consider
how she does until now
yeah I do yeah I mean it's all about the
exploration and Who am I and what am i
capable of and how do I reckon with this
thing that I thought was bad and wrong
and sick and how it's something that I
can use and help people with or you know
deep in a relationship that she feels
strongly about yeah
the Aubry if you only played Lenny like
what he was great when you meet Lenny
she's she's a great character so was it
like they get to transform her episode
by episode to what we just saw sister
does a full unleashing as a magenta to
the music um it was a wild ride man
I'm totally fun I kind of knew the broad
strokes of where my knees would end up
but I can know how I would get there and
navigating that was really challenging
really fun what was it like working
answer to the physicality of the
character like we just saw you know she
she moves a certain way there are
certain things almost pantomime dancers
going on to clothing with kind of a
whole journey along the way for that
yeah like a dream come true but for me
the most fun kind of work is to like
just figure out not a psychopath like
move around for me and I was just so
grateful but just that's the script had
things that were written in such a kind
of dreamlike way where we could kind of
be really creative and and just take
them you know weird risks or whatever as
a jean you relevation she's got all of
her back but briefly she's shaken
element know she's she's a lot of the
popsicle and Joe has sex in 20 years
it was almost more heartbreaking to get
in back and not getting back completely
and then cheap so yeah well do you think
you have given it was this quest to get
immaculate virgin which succeeded
will unlock them again without sort of
disillusion horrible that just go to
they are or do you think you know given
who she is we think hard to say little
each little adage
I mean the good others that helps break
the turn but you know in some ways you
might think I tried and it work and then
whenever a character I love these two
another incredibly individual dynamics
if you have a house you know first Hall
initially starting the show because
everyone industry to the character names
everyone looks confused
did you open again go exactly host work
with the two characters I don't think
you know how I've heard
other issues of joint tenancy which were
still working on but the exciting notion
that my Kiki kind hood pale of him
shares a body with a warrior to tear to
jr. mr. hallease notion that we took on
two before we met each other yes yes I
knew I mean what I heard Taunton Ella I
think he told me more who carry one and
then he was like all socialism you
remember we were in a dance studio one
day so that and offered with their
witnesses we're always looking for how
to take on the next trip and that wasn't
a that she started to experiment with
that sort of Chorus Line walk that
demonic or emotional day that we shared
well it's like fun if I try to describe
very very like you know would you save
their siblings were her child or best
friends resolved it just this
indefinable
like what I found that we discarded
differences like I said appropriately
for our characters like I find myself
describing the Laura sibling and I feel
like you more often describe she'd love
to learn older siblings okay Jeremy your
character is anyone who's thinking about
your disability it's kind of easy to
make glass off so not being able to
remembering everything but then the
options kind of sounds like a kind of
awful to remember everything
do you think this to guide you can
sitting on a lot of sorrow because you
know you have to kind of take a good if
add together in the open way yeah I
think that's one of the first things
that Noah talked to me about like this
completely cool remembering everything
would think about how to be a burden and
I think you know as the season goes on
we see that the time we can be kind of
straightforward and black from the
patients that the other character that
and like need to kill people right away
and that way I think he's definitely
thinking all out of trauma and I think
he said he's fearless when Tom is
expressing his opinion
to be seen John Legend and been through
so much now I have to turn after some
sequence you questions around how much
you're willing to say but maybe you can
tell us about you know obviously we left
off with that you know on money and
Oliver going one direction and then what
happened - we are going to meet the
shadow king Amahl Farouk who will be
played by a fabulous actor named Syed
neck valium we last saw in Wonder Woman
and my first saw is in three kings where
he said what is Officer Michael Jackson
which is one of the great lines of all
[Music]
society will join us and add to that
what now will be a trio with he and
Audrey and and Jemaine commands wanted
to be here today but could but you see
lunge is really far away
so and then obviously we have a love
story but this is that at its core is
really an epic love story between two
people who literally physically can't be
together in the challenge of that and
you know it season one was the honeymoon
I think season two we're going to have
to explore all right now you have to
figure out like how does this actually
work
you know Lauren had worked on the extra
cells that uses various fake villains I
mean I was so excited when I realized to
change okay
what were your conversations that know
about doing that character and you know
sort of stealth putting a pretty notable
villains in the comics since Michelle
won we had a little bit discussed in the
movies that has decided not to pursue at
the time and this is the best way Noah
can you talk about that using the
territory gives a cute look you know
with show begin ask a lot of questions
about willing to the complex and the
professor Eck's of it all and some
people motto maybe we'll never see any
other character in the comic course but
then yeah the sort of thing I ended up
being for Israel I just remember so
vividly rereading that that issue where
Professor X had had the battle winter
with the shadow king and you know the
two of them just literally sitting in a
restaurant no one would ever know
anything was going on but this whole
battle is raging in this astral state
and then at the end of it when the
Shadow King loses his head down on the
table or something so memorable about
that just that again they're taking
something that should be action and
turning it into something so much more
interesting and that was definitely the
idea that that you know Xavier had
defeated this guy and then he went off
and had a kid that
and it's always seem to me like that was
really interesting thinking we can start
to build into where at first you think
okay it's Division three and it's the
plucking that of rebel to get the Empire
and while we're you know getting ready
to fight the apartments to negotiate his
memory and you know try to help them see
that that means that he's a you know
he's not mentally ill but when they go
in there we discover the real enemies
with him I thought that was sort of
subversive afternoon
yeah Jeff we spoken before about sort of
what sort of makes a marble hero I think
David is absolutely that regard
no II think sort of stands out among via
the horrible Pantheon well we have been
a good thing that makes marble different
into each connecting parties why these
characters connect the audience is
because they start out as regular folks
people have hopes and dreams and in
reality their life is is poop just kiss
me on it and so remember her to virtue
so David character would I love what am
i and it really was Noah who came in and
said like we're going to present him in
a very realistic way of somebody who has
mental illness and then this one is
going to be no he's a mutant and he's
not only that capable of incredible
either greatness or destruction and
we'll never know like we'll never know
what next week that's part of the
illness of it all that you don't know
whether or not that and what it peels
back to the Ferger driven and sort of
everybody where I love about this cast
is
know was writing it everybody kept
secret and and they slowly it appealed
which only means that there's more
sequence to come and and that's a reason
to keep enjoying job and and hopefully
we're sure in for the right guy but I'm
going to come from the very beginning
when I first saw the first cut of it you
know my reaction was you know it painted
it it's not the most one of your stories
and some so there's no real and it's a
toy that is there's no reliable very
because there's there's things that are
in the past in this thing
there's things that are acting down is
missing David and just in case that's
not confusing enough if memories or
false
so don't really know and there's a
lovely beautiful shot the moment where
says considered steal and she says yes
we love you and I said that we get back
where we'll go arm 20 in an unlike he
lives in the future and we're just
living where we are so I thought if
anyone wanted me to this triple question
there's a lot of people wanted me to
just ask what the hell took gave it at
the end but you can show the direct
manager on this phone
but sequencing a product that actually
was mentioned in passing earlier a and
OCS dark Rose asked to dance and Rachel
enjoy some of the Bollywood style damn
team and how long how long did it take
to learn that and the Gradle enjoyed it
I don't think they enjoyed it at all and
I'll tell you why or you telecom I today
yeah I enjoyed the room yesterday not
that they did violent good was Megan so
every time we thought it and we called
cut you would be green it's not a great
gun style to perform when you feel
nauseous a lot of skinny the truth but
every time they yell five six seven
eight in a big smile mignon attack
fighter paid well but but doctor side
the actual learning process was one of
her residence eleven yeah that was I
mean I love the me the counter uses the
room there isn't a show full either
limited on some political timing bill
dance with the broom during that fight
that host England sorry present of my
eyes work
and is the most moving Johnson sequel
that ever witnessed with my eyes do you
feel that I would dump treat with the
treat I talked about the decision was
very easy sequences and scenes and
character moments or any of the cast is
there a day on set it does whether it's
a horrible compose here not hopefully
not up stands out to you as they okay
this is like the world of legions what
I'm doing today filming that first
season oh wow yeah I know I really felt
that way when we were shooting in the
astral plane because I've never been
there before it's just green everywhere
and in the mind
I thought that thing we did were word we
had no voice you know speaking I him
command no one could hear you that was
difficult but that was really an
interesting scene to work on together
they didn't turn sound off we were
actually I think that you had to pretend
you compared to people who you know that
was some was an interesting guy
anyone else oh there were days when
amber did a wonderful stuff double or
rehearsing with five or six stunt guys
and laying them back just be standing on
the sidelines booth business or to walk
through just kind of the back hall of
the studio to see him by himself dancing
with a broom I'm just going to turn a
corner and be like there is they'll keep
walking there's more Gators we're coming
Jerry baby think if I got to you well
the memory still has from the pilot
shooting the action sequence you did
that like 20 times at the end running up
and down the side of that hill and
carrying a tommy gun up and down waiting
to the Sun that's those things with me
racial Gann was it the bomb-aimer
sequence or something else better
[Music]
what well ended earlier but when I
walked on the white rooms that it was
very kind of Kubrick as we were putting
it like the bathroom and the lighting
and that was that was I remember not a
good moment the red master sorry
authoring and you're almost the wiper
don't looking in and out of man anyway I
had a very trippy effect on your eyes
and everything that got very blue in the
white room we had things would happen
and it was very cool to see that
actually translate to the screen the
very very tricky sequence to watch where
it starts a few questions they having
for a minute and two strikes out there
somewhere for dark first and it's right
there but I'll read one more question
for Twitter before we get audience
question nutrition the other big Oh asks
what we see more David huge or
adolescence in the coming season you
know we've come to terms with everything
will climax still be a part of it or we
kind of more stay in the present for him
yeah we noted story pretty well now but
we don't know everybody's story right
well now so so I think there are other
people who we may see where they came
from and how it brought them to this
moment so yeah well the captain you and
Alex maybe think perhaps the shadow king
flashbacks like the in order it could be
yeah now
we'll get our money's worth every
character on the show
I can't obviously I have a slight
character issue I like a lot of them and
I do believe that that you know the more
you shift point of view the more empathy
you build even for characters who you
think are supposed to be villains the
more interesting it becomes when you
know when when they have to face off
against each other so now work enough
we're definitely going to go deeper I'm
legally obligated to ask you this watch
back maybe they can include a prophet or
a certain fall Dallas area
[Music]
[Applause]
very good right hae-jin want to jump up
and your car keys behind well you were a
talk show with that fat man I guess you
call it the box yeah he had no idea what
the show was educated on television you
would seem very very into the idea great
first place a second ago but I'm
wondering if professor at the show would
be bold what a script supervisor oh yeah
I don't I don't
look no Viet without what that would
what that would be I mean on some level
or depends on who would do it
and when we reach them on the story if
it's on Aaron's people one of the young
one is I don't know yet be great if you
were older than your dad it could be a
like a Babies R Us right I feel like
both Lesseps are in there yeah I think
as long as the Asian one than ever yet
lobster I'm Miranda thank you guys
my question is for Noah and I want to
know if we're going to learn more about
all of his past and how he knew more
about babies the shadow kings and the
rest of everyone else's summer
Summerland you'll get a lot of time on
his hand and that ice cube I guess and
was and was watching I think we will
I've had thinking sort of a really
interesting character that I I thought
we would get to later in the season but
when I started writing episode 4 I just
for some reason started it in the giant
ice cube with the guy in the Safari they
were talking to the camera and it was in
like oh there is you know he's no fun
and Jermaine was the only one who could
who could really play him and you know I
think we should learn learn more
certainly and he and gene and
in there and we will in the second year
see a lot more of that spoiler hi I'm
Sarah my question is for Dan at David a
very specific safety made during those
big accident
these brilliant tents and full of rage
and sometimes joy those luxuries what
you're thinking when you make
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
once again pursuit
it's like topography I guess working
through a lot of things without yeah of
the blood vessels because the one of the
questions was the great thing about and
those you know he's not so conscious
about that there was never a moment
where he was like oh I have to do the
super powers thing that seems a little
silly to me I mean it was just such an
integral part of the character and he
approached it you know in a very
grounded and dramatic way and you know I
really appreciated that a lot of them
come from the comics you know the frames
where you have had very very intense
close-up on David's face what I was
going on some of those expressions our
inability to directly from it they're
very inspired thank you hi my name is
Sofia and you guys my favorite show I've
seen a lot of years
[Applause]
you come across developments about the
creative risk that you are able to take
in the show with the material and you
guys all taken tremendous creative risk
can you tell us about something that
either scared you or was extreme or
uncomfortable that you as an actor tried
and it worked or it didn't work and it
was funny story I was saying the dance
sequence that I had to do was definitely
scary for me and uncomfortable and fun
and I think that's a really great
example of why being on the show so fun
because Noah will write you know one
sentence that could be interpreted a
million different ways and so it's just
really yeah really exciting to kind of
be able to take those originals bring
them to life and whatever way you dream
up anyone else want to build up a risky
thing unity on the on the show really
there's a lot of risky play in the banjo
they just counted in all of them okay
expose of it hi I'm terrified I cared so
much more about whether masses calming
appropriate a sort of emotional like
innocence and purity in waiting till was
bid a cast around how you do when you're
like 13 or the Rainbow Connection and
I'm wondering how were dancing that
evening that innocence this one you've
influenced and never looks gone
is she still kind of be marinara or is
he crushable
[Music]
she's asking for a friend
[Music]
I wasn't interesting thing for me
because suckers character who can
literally blame every bad thing that
he's done or thought that he's had on
this other entity that was in him and
now that entity is gone so I think
there's a danger and sort of staying
long good now so every thought I have or
decision that I make is the good side of
me but now he has to face up to the fact
that without that thing in him he's just
like everybody else he has some good
ideas about it kids and good impulses
and bad impulses and I think that would
be interesting to see the hubris
potentially that you might that he might
fall under the delusion that he is you
know he's all good he he's a hero
everything he does this are oh yeah you
know you know the coming food there's a
lot still going on in man you know with
the removal of just one entertain is
still we still a number of issues at
play inside the head so yeah but what
fills that void really a big question in
the second season I think it is we
should figure that out
hello there hello my name's Amanda I'm
really perfect so great um I work in the
medical field
and I was just wondering um multi your
characters pink or a nice light airy are
actually crazy and kind of get in that
mindset to be able to act it out so
realistically does that make sense well
one of my favorite things about this
season was that six hour were where
everyone you know was under the delusion
that they were mental patient enough in
a hospital and what you saw was that
each one of their abilities could
actually double quite convincingly as a
as an issue you know the Melody's grief
and longing for her husband and belief
that he was going to come back or putana
Dee's feeling that he couldn't escape
his memories and you know villain and an
Amber's codependency and I think that
really brought it I hope for the actors
that going into it you know what their
characters could be and they were
experiments
hi my name is Robin and my question oral
the active medicine given the core
nature of the Shaw period what tell me
do you like to see your parents or felt
a musical number of any song in carrier
what would you want your character to
see ain't coming down til the Sun comes
up by Garth Brooks
[Music]
I want to thank my man from funny girl
[Applause]
we have to confer of course three on one
you can destroy pendant generating I
know I did it on mama boys
[Music]
Rachel dad what song lies in the heart
it is needed pink boy wish you were here
[Applause]
hi I'm Emily Berkeley in the person who
suffers from a mental illness I just
wanted to thank you guys for the way you
portrayed David filament I think you did
a great job you look forward to current
social events for inspiration on how to
portray to divide between Jews and
non-jews of course all thank you for for
saying that it's very important to me
that this show not be a gimmick to tell
a comic book story pretending to be
amended on this story I think one of the
interesting things about playing with
reality is is that we realized when we
look at it the reality is an agreement
between a majority of people about
what's normal and then the people who
don't fit into that definition of normal
are applicable we just want to say that
there aren't tangible physical illnesses
that people suffer from but but I feel
like if you look at a character like
David who for 10 or 15 years has been
suffering from hearing voices seeing
things you know even when you convince
him that those things were real he still
was suffering he still developed a
personality major on the idea
one who's sort of haunted by my life
that doesn't just go away once you tell
someone that they're but they're saying
so I think we want to really continue to
play with that aspect for everybody of
how they define themselves and and you
know how they keep themselves healthy as
you can see for creating most Nikki
wonderful piece of television I think
anyone here will see what I like to know
who is crowned like Tiffany and how to
like Co character development it's easy
to break up together time you know and
what you ride unimportant
Jameson to chug I know I want to do it
tango with Oliver can make it out of you
one
not the universal anyone else we want to
dance like neither of us have ever
danced before
all right I could be in a band player
leave those do you know which is even
more singing maybe Jack everybody just
really wanted to play music and ride
horses
[Music]
thank you very much
i Lee Jin an awesome show though it's
got a lot of stuff going on here there's
one quick thing with Mitch Noah well yes
you come here and come Kannan I am at
comic-con right
[Applause]
I thought I can write as being a buildin
on developing a box which you guys might
be excited about and I'll just say two
words to you the first one is doctor and
the second one is two
[Applause]
you